ah so we're gonna start with I really
miss SARS uh I
I really hate to see it go man I really
was happy watching Chinese people
walking around uh not trying to cough
you know you know
I just love watching Chinese people get
the pressure apply looking at them like
waiting for them to cough you know you
when you was working with them you were
just looking around if you cough
at this Chinese dude coughs I it was
just fantastic because every other
disease they blame on black people I
can't get enough of it yeah
I'm watching uh TV monkey pox and
he's doing some magical disease white
people breaking out with this and uh
and so I'm looking and they're doing the
report and they show a composite sketch
of some rat uh from Africa which would
which which means he's black and they
drew it
first of all I'm like What's the how do
you know the difference between some
some uh black rat and some rat from the
Bronx you know that's the Puerto Rican
hash so they they might as well drew a
hat backwards and so
so this is the monkey pox Cooper watch
out for them watch out for the dirty uh
black rat and then
uh uh an attack it attacked uh now white
people don't really have an animal
representative of themselves
but if you were to think of a few one
would be a bald eagle and the other
would be a prairie dog and that's what
it attacked so it was almost just like a
newscast being on the lookout for
something right uh he
he a bit uh some poor defenseless uh
prairie dog just watching the game and
stole his wallet and bit him in the
shoulder and gave him
I'm watching the uh this bug show with
the locusts man
black locusts from Africa whoa watch out
for black locusts
African eyes that's what they call
Africanized big black locusts watch out
cause they they eat up all the crops and
they don't tip and and watch out
watch for the locusts
and y'all know about the monkey
got charged up with all kind of the
monkey Haze or Ebola
I'm not even really scared of A's
anymore
I mean because how can you with magic
you see Magic Johnson he looks fantastic
I can't be afraid he looks wonderful
he's had AIDS for 15 years
what kind of age he got the good kind I
want
he's been he's been open in movie
theaters
and Starbucks for the last 15 years I
want that kind of age give me that
make me a better entrepreneur I need
that
Patricia got AIDS good I want to open a
trucking company because
this crowd is tough
Chinese people
but the black people in the Chinese
people wrote I was laughing at the thing
right but they couldn't
that's young girls for you boy young
girls do that y'all the only thing good
about young girls y'all young girls you
know y'all young y'all look delicious
you know other than that
and they getting bigger too man these
young bros man damn you see him with
this I think it's something they put in
the chicken and all that stuff all that
that you know what I mean they walk
around big I saw this woman walking down
the street I was like damn you flying
how old are you she was like four
[Music]
you got some nice titties for fall